[Music]
it's been a long time since we've played
old benjamin clips okay can i start by
saying that
it's been a long time since owen was
interesting it's been a long time since
i've played quite a while
since i've been waiting for this all day
so owen benjamin last week about two
weeks ago i think went on back on sam
tripoli's show
and i'll play a little clip and then
we're going to delve a little bit deeper
into the whole thing
but uh here he is man it's been a while
since we've seen him on the screen huh
it has been a while since we've had this
beautiful
um we got two guys that are known to us
on this
check this out it all fact and you'll
see the video you smug little [ __ ] who
are you talking to you why
because you're being smug man all
yeah
right
are you calling me a smug [ __ ]
because you're acting smug dude i'm not
acting smug i'll read the style what
have i done that smug owen what have i
done i'm having a conversation with you
why am i being smug
i don't understand it
you just brought in the whole feed the
family [ __ ] where i'm what am i taking
away martin's ability to feed his family
that's not what i'm saying that what i'm
doing am i taking away your ability to
feed
so that's just a little clip we're going
to play a little bit more so far what do
you think though
it's lit this is pretty so far can i
play one more little clip before we get
into it okay
okay but i'll get into that
when it comes to jew world order stuff
okay
i didn't talk to you i don't think the
jews run anything okay so let's i just
want to have this conversation with you
and again you i'm gonna after i say this
say whatever
you've been
pretty outspoken in thinking that jews
run everything so i'm gonna go back to
our old style with owen benjamin and i
think this is the fair way to do it
because a lot of people when we ever
cover owen or even when we cover brennan
and stuff like that or any of these
people people like oh you go in there
and you find the clips you go and you
find the clips to make them look stupid
now we have a rule in this game in this
in the studio okay whenever we get a
long-form video like this we kind of
just skip around
so i picked
you guys saw me before the show i picked
an arbitrary starting point okay this is
about 16 minutes into a 58 minute video
i have we none of us have watched this
except for the clips that i just showed
you okay
all right strap in
to undercut the united states government
the united states dollar and bring in a
crypto uh [ __ ] uh currency and i
think that's why i that that's the price
why are you on the platform he's talking
about i'm not sure what platform it is
he's talking about one of those
platforms you know that he's saying it's
[ __ ] because they use crypto and not
you know money or whatever when it's
based on crypto why even you go there if
you don't like it yeah i don't think you
understand i don't start from the start
i've had multiple discussions with
multiple new channels there it is always
does
rockfin is that what it's called what's
what's the what's this is the one that i
would the one that alex stein was
talking to us about that new social
media site where you get paid for it it
was oh yeah i don't i know what you mean
but i don't remember exactly starts
after the one that seems like a pyramid
scheme ray tokens it is always but it's
totally not appropriate
this this is sorry
yeah
the pay and everything is in ray tokens
there's no way that any rock rock finn i
believe i believe is what i'm talking
about what it is buddy moves forward on
that website that does not know that it
is paid in criticism
the problem is i make fun of crypto i
talk about how
you put a prisoner in a cell box
block chain crypto crypt you put oh
because the word chain is in it hold on
oh god we haven't done this in so long
owen is still so stupid we haven't done
this in so long owen's the epitome of
that guy
owen is the epitome of that dumb person
that's trying to find codes and meaning
and everything
so blockchain's evil now look last we
left off it was like the moon and stuff
i i
last time we really recovered him hard
he was burning his kids dinosaur books
dead people in a crypt you put chains on
their [ __ ] feet and you put them in a
cell block you will only be able to buy
and sell based on a public ledger that's
what they want to bring in now and so
that's the taboo topic so that's not
what crypto is at all
those people want to play a little
[ __ ] song and dance and and talk
about how they're truthers and they
allow you to talk about vaccines the
vaccine [ __ ] is over it's over it's now
gone why don't you talk about it owen
when a lot of places weren't doing that
forever
for a while
damn that scam's over right now it's
about total scam right yeah but they
were clipping people talking about
why did he get kicked off of rockfin or
he just didn't want to be a part of it
because of the crypto i know there's
some owensburgs out there that could
probably give me a little bit more
information she but eno hit a mom's
[ __ ] on [ __ ] only fans for sure
like that's freedom but i can't [ __ ]
make fun of shaq looking like a [ __ ]
gorilla oh that's not it you just said
this isn't
no i mean i think you should be allowed
to make jokes
an idiot but he's making a valid ball he
is making an actual valid point see
again people go you just do you mean
people you just say no this this is fair
he he is 100 right there yes owen you
are correct about about jokes you said
it's about crypto right now it is about
crypto and that's why that's that's the
joke
have you seen your coinbase account
lately
no are you laughing or crying when you
go there i don't look i just laugh now i
don't look at her from this i'm not
doing this because i want to be on
rockville martin could have just
apologized he could have said because
we're texting back and forth all day and
he's like he kept holding a moral line
on me and that's a problem for me and
you know me that's a problem it's one
thing if you go hey man i got this thing
going i you know dude the story you just
told makes me like him more where it's
like hey man i'm really into greco-roman
wrestling i saw it was happening i
[ __ ] like crypto you're kind of
[ __ ] things up do you mind if you
just leave i'd be like no problem
so apparently the site his site runs on
crypto but owen has been talking [ __ ]
about crypto
and that's what got him that's what it's
seen look again we are
we are p you know like we're p you know
like those games like the arkham games
or whatever games where you have to look
for evidence and start piecing together
what's happening yeah that's how it is
with owen you kind of have to piece
together what's going on
when he says hey man
i got a [ __ ] i got a [ __ ] uh
problem with your morality
i'm like you know what i'm gonna i'll
give him a little credit here by the way
because i also got cigarette
lost a little bit of weight he's looking
all right owen's looking okay cows yeah
he's looking okay yeah he's come a long
way from screaming
outside in the shed now he's screaming
inside in his home to be fair now he's
screaming at sam tripoli which is
still kind of weird
fight this because you're going to be
manipulating people into thinking that
blockchain is freedom like transsexual
is freedom like the the vaccine will
make it go back to normal and i dude i'm
a more i [ __ ] yeah but see owen here's
the thing and here's here's the problem
where i like
he makes us do things that are a little
different right like
no i don't think trans stuff is normal i
i don't right
just like you know i
that that's fine my problem is when they
force kids to do it and all that [ __ ]
and they try to normalize it and that's
fine but nobody is making you by crypto
owen nobody is forcing right like he
well i guess his i will hold on a second
now hold on i just thought about this i
guess maybe his take is is that he has
to use crypto if he's going to be on
that rockford site because that's what
they pay out in and that's probably what
he was bitching about oh okay yeah yeah
sorry we're piecing this together
fight with morality it's not about money
for me right i have no debt no mortgage
no addiction i mean i battle some
addictions but it's like battle a lot of
addictions
we're from upstate new york dude i mean
that's right right i'm sorry i can't
have merch because you're you're more
you're more of a big apple connoisseur
do every does everyone in upstate new
york battle addiction is that a thing
uh there is
a certain level of
boredom
in upstate new york to buffalo and there
is
a significant amount of colleges in
upstate new york so
uh no not everyone battles addiction but
par it's upstate new york's it's a wild
place it is fun
a lot of partying going on it's weird
because like upstate new york is like
the is the south but for new york even
though it's north
you know
there's more land there's there's more
republicans too
yeah i mean we both have a little voice
in us going like change your personality
go down i know trust me i'm i relate
right
but it's like my battle isn't i i don't
want rockfin to fail because of people
like you and people like jaren and
people like weiss and people that i like
that it's just the people don't like
this so when this so hold on a second
owen i'm sorry
owen got kicked off of youtube which i
think did win
owen got kicked off of youtube okay
which i think was [ __ ] one should
not have been kicked off of youtube so
let's start with that but
moving forward from that point fine owen
goes and he goes to d live right
dlive doesn't like a [ __ ] they kick him
off they kicked a lot of people off and
then they came back then no one goes to
another i don't know which other side he
goes to he doesn't like their [ __ ] then
he leaves their site then no one goes to
write so oh and look here's the thing
unfortunately there's going to be no
perfect sight that's going to bend to
your will in terms of what you're going
to do whether you're right or you're
wrong so you kind of have to and i know
this is hard for owen
but you kind of have to try to play the
game a little bit if you want to see on
the internet right yeah like there's
ways to
have some fun and tiptoe do a little
dance
[ __ ] listen to our live reads yeah this
was revealed when he did this public
thing of deleting my channel he could
have had me delete it he could have been
like hey man
uh we got this thing going on do you
mind just deleting your channel it was
embarrassing it was embarrassing to have
that happen again after i told people to
go to rockfan okay
debunk the holocaust like they asked me
not to do
what
he didn't do it though
so his way
of hold on merch i got to point this out
because i'm thinking i'm thinking how
this meeting went
his way of meeting them in the middle
look i won't mention the smokestacks or
the maternity wards
all right hand to god i promise
but i am gonna bash your platform
and the uh currency it's based on
i miss owen so much he's season they say
miss this
why did youtube kick him off
well because of all that holocaust
debunking
on account of
mostly that
i never said i never said to her jews i
never said jews are [ __ ] trying to
hurt us i'm just doing comedy and i
don't need to be on there no question
someone brought it up with the chat and
we forgot to make what happened that
unauthorized tv thing that you're
raising money for
true shouldn't that be where you're
streaming on
what happened with that
didn't he have a falling out with the
point fighter diddy
i don't know i don't keep up with it i
can't keep up with the lore
i don't even need to make any drama but
like
it's this morale it's this inverted
morality i understand that owen okay i
understand that but you did i don't know
how long the video was [ __ ] on
martin okay and listen i understand
dude yeah okay let me tell you something
man i'm just going to say this to you
man you when we first had our problem
i'm going to say something when we first
had our problem way back in the day and
you [ __ ] texted my burner phone
okay
and
he's doing the okays though okay
you said something by the way guys
i don't know was this on sam's
episode sam i know you like sometimes to
pop people and stuff we're just being
transformative here bud please don't i
just want to at least try to i'm trying
the nice way please please please don't
it resonated with me and i didn't really
understand it because i hadn't had kids
right there yeah okay okay here's what
we're gonna do
we're gonna skip are we going to skip
ahead you think of it yeah okay
transformative skip
green top hat a hatred of irish people
it's no i i miss just skipping around
his videos i got to go back a little bit
i got to go back i got to see missed
something oh why are you bringing up
jews and blacks if it's a
i gotta go back a little bit more we
went too far i went too far ahead i'm
gonna go right here ghosting me
because i didn't answer your tax rate
off for five days four days five days
for five days
i hit you up and i go hey man let's do a
podcast
two days later you're like are you
[ __ ] ghosting me two or three days
later
but the point is the point is oh i mean
can we defend owen here for a second
with sam and scheduling
podcast
how many times were you supposed to be
four times producer reached out yeah and
and we try to go on three or four times
i want to meet my mom i think it was
three times and then i think the third
wasn't even our idea and then the third
time they reached out we went yeah we
don't even want to don't even bother
well though they reached out because
we're supposed to be on it one like oh
can you come on a form like i can't we
do a show at four i can't
well first time they just blew us off
yeah true
no read these i'll read them right now
okay go i'm making an epic video that's
gonna make rockfin look [ __ ] [ __ ]
in fact right as a friend i'm telling
you don't be on the shill side or your
audience is going to think you're an
idiot you're going to get that as well
owen
so he text sam and told them
it's one thing to [ __ ] hate this dude
but it's another thing to tell tell
somebody else you should also get off of
rockfin
yeah that seems a little odd man
anti-semitic talk bro i do jokes about
jews for jews
i have no hate at all fact and you'll
see the video you smug little [ __ ] who
are you talking oh here's the here's
where the clip came from here we go
you why
because you're being smug man you're
like all right [ __ ] yeah why are
you calling me a smug [ __ ]
because you're acting smug dude i'm not
acting smug i'll read the style what
have i done that smug owen what have i
done i'm having a conversation with you
why am i being smug
i don't understand it
you just brought in the whole feed the
family [ __ ] where i'm what am i taking
away martin's ability to feed his family
that's not what i'm saying not what i'm
doing am i taking away your ability to
feed
that obviously
because i related to what you're saying
okay
i'm okay relating to what you said there
that was actually not
i'm relating but like not in a valid way
dude
i was making money on rock way owen
100
in a valid way
because i'm that guy too
okay what guy i've been censored on a
lot of places owen
yeah and if you got kicked off a place
that i was on i would never show for the
other side
that's a weird that's a weird thing to
ask of people yeah that's kind of not
fair right like if i get kicked if
nightwave ever gets kicked off youtube
rice you need to delete rotc no but
that's like saying you got kicked off of
twitter that you i'll never plug your
twitter royce you'll be like why i
didn't do anything to you like what
ever you know i don't give a [ __ ] about
his friends with them either throwing
out chill oh there must be a line you're
a comedian dude take it seriously
well i'm not laughing at anybody right
now
what's the life look at the line sam
what's the line what's the line tell me
the line for jokes see this line sam i
have a feeling something bad is coming i
don't know why you know when you have a
bad intuition
jews is it gorillas is it bananas let's
go through let's go through the lines is
the book of mormon the lie when you just
studied in your family about your jokes
you just said that it's about kryptos
then that means
so it's crypto jewish gorillas that
throw bananas at you that is a problem
that sounds like a a pretty awesome
comic book or like cartoon it sounds
like a donkey kong reboot yes it does
why are you bringing up jews and blacks
if it's about cryptic because that's
what martin said it was about and that's
what you said publicly it was about you
said that i don't want to watch the line
because of anti-semitism you said the
word anti-semitism
owen owen
i want to ask you something do you
believe at any point you said some
anti-smack [ __ ] ever
i mean
yeah
yeah but watch this merc do you think
you've ever seen any anti-semitic [ __ ]
are we going on the record or off the
record have you ever seen an
anti-semitic
but the answer is no we've never said
that of course not
say do it smart owen
in my life no never you didn't have a
[ __ ] closest i ever came you didn't
have a [ __ ] uh uh that mascot and
that's the the [ __ ] gravity covered
that when he first got the mask remember
that your mask and doing that that's not
anti-semitic going on no
oh and come on man okay so if i wear an
irish hat and a beard
what the [ __ ] are you talking about dude
you know what i'm talking about
you're just you're you're owen
if you wearing a big irish beard one of
those big hats i would have corey flocks
for sue you immediately that's what
would it work that's what would happen
if i wear a green top hat and an irish
beard on st patty's day does that mean i
hate irish people no but you'll be
dressed like mr hat was remember mr
maggie mr hat was a big beard and a
that's right what unfortunately in some
places that there isn't what do you have
a problem with it owen you noticing that
you think you you haven't gotten in
trouble for that it's laughable because
you have all of it by who
by every [ __ ] website that's kicked
you off owen we're re-fucking writing
history here okay that's my point
answer the question as yourself oh and
listen here's you i think that mask is
anti-semitic yes or no
i mean yeah
it's i think i look owen
i think what the point he's trying to
make
and i think you're you're partially
right here you should be allowed to joke
and do whatever you want i agree with
you on that but
a green
irish hat and a red beard
it wouldn't be
like
as insulting
to irish people you know i mean yeah
but then again if you were wearing an
irish get up and like beating your wife
and drinking you know and passing out i
would still be a cop that would be a
police uniform
i still wouldn't be offended
of course it is so is a green top hat a
hatred of irish people it's uh i it's
not hey the actual liar you lied no
oh not a liar lying is better i would i
would honestly
respect owen moore
if he were honestly goes yeah i was
making jew jokes and yeah sure some
people thought they were anti-semitic
but the point is i should be allowed to
do it then i would be with oh and be
like yeah he's right owen's wrong and
that he's spiraling trying to convince
everyone he's not anti-semitic when when
the real thing should be even if i am
anti-semitic i should be allowed to say
my opinion and people who want to listen
to it shouldn't tune in i agree with
that part i agree
bad for recovery and you know it you
know that oh and i'm killing it in
recovery brother
bro
i am way better at recovering from my
addiction than you are i just meant to
tell you this is the weirdest
show-off ever all right you smug bastard
why are you being so smug you're so
killing it that you're lying right to my
face lies is what makes you really
highline oh and i'm lying about what so
if i do a parody of an irish person is
that the hate patties that he's really
like
why why you really i'm starting to think
you might be anti-irish oh and here's
the thing though everything about irish
people i've never seen you talk about
irish people controlling the media
i think that it's not just the mask i
think that look for example oh really we
don't control the media i ordered an old
man mask and they sent me a black old
man mask you see here
you see
now i'm not going to put it on bill
o'reilly
sean hannity oh hey laura
those are all people oh oh what is
people who get lower ratings than tucker
carlson
[Laughter]
today is actually celebrating the
genocide of [ __ ] pagans in [ __ ]
ireland if you really want to get deep
brother that's what it is
what you're not answering the question
you're being dishonest no because oh and
you're acting like all things are equal
and you know they're not you're no i i
think all men and women are equal when
it comes to the community if i was sam
tripoli my argument wouldn't be that
argument be like look i agree with you
you should be allowed to say those
things unfortunately owen these [ __ ]
make the rules and if you don't play the
game they're going to kick you off i
mean that's how it is make all the rules
these [ __ ] irish people that control
the media
you act like all things are equal and in
an idealistic world owen you should be
able to do every joke you want to and
guess what owen i do all those jokes in
hollywood
at the comedy store with my jewish
friend's approval sam put the mask on
and huh could you do that
can you go to the comedy store and that
mask
that was no because cause they'll think
he owns it
oh no the boss is here everyone get to
work guys i think there's some kind of
hollywood producer out there tonight
make sure you guys do a really good set
i do jew jokes black jokes day jokes
everything i just made fun of everybody
you do okay
yeah and they like it so don't sit there
and like i don't do it all right nobody
you're pretending
martin's thing martin runs a a [ __ ]
platform
why is every platform that tries to
compete with youtube always just turn
into this weird [ __ ] show
like it's you know like odyssey getting
into twitter fights with other people
like it's it's a weird like
mix of things it's a cosmic gumbo
where did you hear that it's from it's
from it's from i think you should leave
oh when the big guy with the beard does
the was the cop movie and then they
interview him on aol movie watch he's
like so what do you think about the
movie well i called it a cosmic gumbo
gumbo so know that it's a greco-roman
platform but you didn't know a
greco-roman platform is it sounds like a
[ __ ] brett heart move
well then until two minutes ago i know
and then i was a truther platform two
minutes ago
first off that's the problem with all
these french sites
they're not truthful platforms they
shouldn't be here's here's the truth if
you want a good platform it can't be a
truth or platform it can't be a
right-wing platform it can't be a
left-wing platform it has to be a
platform to let you put up your [ __ ]
videos that's it
it's very simple it should be very
simple yeah free speech platform he's
lying and telling people that
everything you talk about people talk
about there already
they already do it everyone
but they're not putting on
[ __ ] jewish masks and dancing around
rubbing coins together remember that
yeah kicked off sam but you have a
history owen that's why history hosting
starts right for guild's awards
movies so one of the leads of a sitcom
did
he just threw his hollywood did he say
that he was the lead of a sitcom he said
one of the leads
is he
sullivan and sons is with tombow
he was one of the leads he was the
[ __ ] like neighbor character right
or whatever oh cool cool
so you were like corey and [ __ ] you
were like [ __ ] not corey uh
uh what what was the neighbor in a step
by step the dumb
one oh the guy lived in the van yeah ah
[ __ ] i forgot his name i know you're
talking yeah oh i know what's my fault i
have four kids in a farm sam yeah is it
cody cody it's cody exactly you're being
a little deceitful little demon
demon
you see you
you just like by the way he's
complaining and then somebody again not
defending sam with some of the stuff
he's saying but but to be fair sam
well out of every you can say whatever
you want about sam sam is giving him a
platform and not censoring him on his
youtube show you know
when you're in denial okay that's my
denial that the ground
is in history here owen what's my
history what's your history why have you
been kicked off several [ __ ]
platforms owen you tell me no
he did and you said that he was lying
you tell me dude you want i will then
shut your mouth for five minutes okay
he is heated
they miss each other yeah on twitter
there was a guy named jesse thorne do
you know my [ __ ] history at all
okay here's the other thing owen
no no not everybody follows your lore
justin thorne now be quiet for like
mommy and daddy are fighting
once in your life dude
why do you think i call you smug you
think that's funny no justin
yelling at me literally you said you
didn't weren't going to get emotional
about this i'm not emotional
i'm not on a boat show
you're
because you won't shut the [ __ ] up i'm
trying to dominate you that doesn't
sound gay at all
i don't care if you dominate brother i'm
not here to get into [ __ ] not your
brother or cheese i'm not your brother
dude okay exactly you want me to explain
i will aaron having a conversation with
you owen quiet dude
quiet for five minutes and i'll explain
to you why i got kicked off i feel like
owen is acting like he hasn't been doing
the majority of the talking when he has
yeah maybe if you give me a chance to
talk
jesse thorne had a three-year-old he was
planning on giving hormones to i called
him out publicly i was accused of being
transphobic and kicked off twitter i
then don't talk i then was allowed to
come back and i said david hoggs this is
the fact is factually what got me kicked
off twitter
david hogg says that uh we shouldn't
have guns but he could uh he can't even
grow pubes yet
the global media said that i was
sexualizing a child
which okay can we defend owen here for a
second we did defend owen when that
happened no i know but
but in hindsight it's even worse
thinking about the media was saying you
were sexualizing a child the same ones
that are cheering on drag shows in
dallas yeah the same ones that are
literally trying to [ __ ] kids yeah and
then like i just want to point out i'll
goof on owen and i'll goof on sam but i
do understand what the real problem is
okay it's and it's definitely not owen
benjamin and it's definitely not sam
tripoli account was banned permanently
that's literally why patreon in writing
and then my touring went to [ __ ] uconn
all these places said you hate trans
people because of a [ __ ]
three-year-old no i have a question
you've seen some of one stand-up
all the politics aside all the jew stuff
aside all this of it
do you really think owen benjamin's a
good stand-up comedian i
don't even think he's a mediocre
stand-up comedian i i mean i'm sure you
were the co-lead of a of a sitcom
i'm not done yet dude
because of a three-year-old that's why i
got kicked off sam all right so don't
[ __ ] pretend that it's because of you
hate all right no that's why you got
kicked off of youtube
that's a different type of youtuber
oh no no i'm not done yet dude
patreon said my pound me too joke was
mocking
hashtag me too it's not pound me too
well that was his funny that was that's
his hilarious is that his stand-up yeah
oh no
the
the victims of sexual abuse i said oh
dude i'm going out to see how me too
pound me too everyone's so thirsty
in writing that's why i was kicked off
patreon upon me too now it's a hacky
joke i did it five [ __ ] years ago i
was kicked off paypal because of um
caitlyn jenner woman of the year now
dude that's why you one night one night
i got close to anti-semitism quote
unquote one night i was drunk and i was
crying one night
one night one time
but here's the thing that bothers me
owen on principle i would stand up for
you
but we've
don't give me that one night [ __ ]
how many videos have we seen
countless ducks go to our page and watch
them 100 they're there
my friend died in afghanistan and i was
like i knew about the war lobby and i
was a [ __ ] emotional fake marine
friend i can't keep up
that was the one night i was who was his
fake marine friend again the molecular
eric nimmer yeah there it is not being
comedic and i was being actually
sad and i cried and i wept for my friend
and that was the one time
uh someone could look at that and say
that guy scares me but other than that
it's all illusions and it's pushed by
this whisper campaign and that's why i'm
calling you out on it because you're
going to say oh you have a history oh
you have an assignment says no i don't
dude i i called out the abuse of
children i wouldn't [ __ ] i dude books
look at all his books bro do you want me
to play the stolen bike song you did on
youtube
i just read the title of yeah you just
read it yeah what
narcissus that's not the n word i was
looking at
oh i know
i was trying not to say it's a book
about a black slacks
likes luger black lex luger exactly
hey froze do you want to read the title
of that book
i'm not falling for that one why not
joseph conrad hey there the words
well go in
hey taper when you clip this can you
bleep that part out things
you you could feel the pain no
quick go back to oh and benjamin will
happen
at the comedy store i know jew jokes
black dude in writing that's why i was
kidding
me owen darling does not mean bad it
doesn't mean magic it was you screaming
passionately on this stream if i didn't
like you i like you owen that way this
is him liking this is somebody he likes
likes you bro i think you're a cool guy
why did this scream this this stream
okay i got good information to pass on
bro and i am that's it
the no see the thing is this you and i
have a certain thing we take we go
different ways out but we have a lot of
the same beliefs okay
but
martin is a good dude
he's a good dude
i don't understand why these people are
first off sam
how about you go i don't give a [ __ ]
what you think about martin and you know
what that's fine you could think about
but why is he why does sam keep
defending this dude so hard
is it because he's making funny from the
ponzi scheme rockfin
yeah because that is a ponzi scheme
in my opinion i didn't say that
my opinion from an outside observation i
believe that that's a ponzi scheme fair
enough he's a tech guy okay
how he reacts
to that it's not us
he's not a 20-something year comic
banging okay he's
hanging in bangkok why do comics think
they're [ __ ] so special
because they're part of i like comics
they're part of a community and a
brotherhood that you wouldn't understand
because you're a civilian i like how he
goes i live in hollywood like that's a
brag
he's a tech guy he's a business dude
okay and his business is no different
than a subway or a mom and pops place he
like well no it's different there's a
lot more racism at a subway
dangerous ass [ __ ] on his website and
he's allowed to say things that won't go
in most places oh okay they won't go but
he's allowed people to make money and
pay their bills when a lot of other
places wouldn't okay i know who else did
that was adolf hitler
sam's got to be regretting this
every moment this goes longer he's got
to be hating this
what
you just compared the owner of rockfin
to adolf hitler
okay
he got a lot of people to pay the bills
anyway here
i had a joke and i can't say it hear me
out last if martin texts me or calls me
and says hey man i'm not gonna morally
good guys man the guys over there are
good dudes man and they're getting
[ __ ] demonized right now maybe he
means that he's like hitler in like that
the numbers are pumped up on rockfin
on rockfin on rockfin on rockfin they're
inflating it they're inflating the
numbers on rockfin yeah
back him up again dude hear me out i
don't hold grudges i only do stuff to
change behavior or to defend myself if
someone's gonna moralize me and ban me
from their play to defend yourself i
have seen you remember when he ripped
into alex jones when alex jones didn't
do anything to him remember that whole
spiel where he went after alex and he
got by the way just a month after alex
led him on infowars to host the third
hour you remember when just he started
saying the crowder was gay just out of
the blue that was you you influenced it
i watched you do it in real time i
watched you do it
yeah maybe i don't know i don't remember
that hey amy you think crowder's bi
remember that yeah
platform i'm gonna defend myself if he
says i've reviewed owen i get that he's
joking he's not a racist dude man and
you know what maybe dude i'm not even
done talk like this is my deal okay bro
now sam has let him talk for a while if
he says owen's not a nazi he doesn't
push poor not child porn whatever [ __ ]
he's trying to imply
and he's obviously doing comedy it's a
little too intense for this platform but
i have no problem with him i will
literally literally say that i have no
problem with him i support rockfin and
that's it but he didn't do that and he's
and he was emailing people
that that i i was cr well free spree
chest has a have a line how is that a
family guy doing comedy from a barn
milking goats and making [ __ ] cheese
that's his line but not [ __ ] all this
other degenerated [ __ ] you know that's
my problem with it and it's a person
i am skipping ahead again
i know i swear to god i'm going to stop
yelling now
at the end of the day when you and i are
uh we're good people you're a good
person and i know you mean well and you
know you mean well and i'm like i'm
gonna be honest with you owen i kind of
live in a place right now where i just
know that right now i'm not the most
popular guy in hollywood okay but i know
this too shall pass
is this like a martyr cast or something
did i miss something are they
commiserating because sam tripoli is
still friends with joe rogan and getting
gigs because of it and one benjamin has
people sending him cash in the mail like
what is this
we're good people that hollywood's done
us bad
really guys hollywood's really [ __ ]
you guys over really bad huh the only
reason that owen has all these followers
is and you'll never admit this right but
if owen did everything that he did but
he wasn't in hollywood before nobody
would be following he would have the
same opinions and you know where he'd be
he'd be somewhere in a [ __ ] corner of
cozy tv screaming the n-word and stuff
owen won't admit this and and this is
the part that maybe he has maybe i'm
wrong but it seems to me that the one
thing owen doesn't say is like i [ __ ]
hate hollywood it's evil and i left it
but the only reason people know about me
is because i was in hollywood yeah he
says that all the time though he's
always denouncing hollywood you saw how
quickly he was
i was
sick i said
why are you wearing that as a badge of
honor i co-starred with steve byrne